the
the philosophical foundation is a
bitcoin like how do you see bitcoin
outside of just
a basic protocol on the basic currency
it seems to be like you said
uh it seems like sturdy ground so what
do you mean by it yeah
yeah so it's not just any protocol for
moving valley around it's not just any
currency it's got specific
rules and values that are embedded in it
and this is an important point is the
bitcoin is the encoding
of certain values which are often
misunderstood
or not acknowledged necessarily
and so it's sort of impregnated with
values
and what they are specifically is a
topic of debate and there have been
civil wars fought over the values
inherent in bitcoin
you know one of them was should bitcoin
be this
cheap scalable the base layer low fee
payments system with an emphasis on p2p
payments
or should it be more of this like gold
like
digital commodity that would eventually
settle infrequently and mainly between
institutions right so that's
fundamentally a conflict of visions
right
uh but the so you know keep in mind that
this is just one man's opinion i don't
speak for bitcoin
right so i would say the key the key
number one value that's embedded in
bitcoin is the notion of
non-discretionary monetary policy
so algorithmic monetary policy as
opposed to human-based monetary policy
satoshi was very clear about that
bitcoin is an alternative to
modern central banking where you have
constant tweaking constant intervention
which satoshi felt leads to credit
bubbles and so on
so bitcoin proposes a completely
non-discretionary monetary policy
um sort of decays over time 50
of the coins were issued in the first
four years and then the next 25 percent
in the next four years
then 12 and a half percent in the next
four years until you get to 21 million
units
and none of those numbers really matter
like it could have been 25 million units
and
it could have been a more aggressive
slope or more gradual slope
but what matters is that this schedule
was proposed
even before the code was public the
schedule was proposed
and then we all collectively agreed to
stick to it
and that is kind of a first for monetary
system
i mean gold kind of has that property
right because
gold the supply of gold above ground
only really increases at one to two
percent a year
so it's it's sort of inhuman which is a
good feature right you don't want to
give humans that much control over it
bitcoin is a much more
you know fastidious approach to that it
really is super concrete about what the
supply schedule is and the fact
crucially that it can't change
so we can't have a bailout of debtors
a lot of people would say a lot of
people had debts denominated in bitcoin
and we needed loose
accommodative monetary policy to bail
them out that's not possible we couldn't
have a jubilee denominated in bitcoin
because the social contract that we've
all
you know bought into and committed to
is that it's not just non-discretionary
so that's sort of one of the first
things
um and i think ultimately that comes
back to
basically a strong respect for property
rights
because if we were to have unanticipated
inflation let's say
you know really charismatic leader
somehow commandeered bitcoin and
convinced everyone that we should have
30 million units and not 21 million
that would basically be dilutive on
everybody that
held bitcoin and had opted into the
21 million set of coins
an additional 9 million unanticipated
would have a dilutive effect on everyone
else
and that would be a covert way of
effectively stealing their purchasing
power
through inflation is that possible that
kind of thing i mean uh
what what's the mechanism of bitcoin
that resists that kind of charismatic
leader
well we've had people that have had
a lot of influence in bitcoin in the
past and they've tried to make changes
to the protocol not as dramatic as that
um but bitcoiners have generally
resisted
those individuals institutions
and they you know bitcoiners have a good
track record of sort of staying true to
to those core values so that you know
the you mentioned
values and and like sticking to the
monetary thing
but there's bigger values uh there's
almost like psychological values that
are instilled in bitcoin uh you make a
point
that bitcoin for many is a vessel quote
for their expectations hopes and dreams
uh can uh the bitcoin protocol support
this kind of complexity of
the human condition so like there's
ideas of freedom
that seem to be spoken about there's a
sort of ideas of um
of i mean even love yeah i mean
some people kind of use it as a meme
like you know bitcoin is love or
something like that
you know um mostly to troll me because i
talk about love all the time
but you know these bigger ideas than
just
the exchange of currencies yeah i mean
bitcoin itself is very uh simple i would
say like ultimately
it doesn't you know pretend to do very
much it really just settles transactions
um but people do superimpose their own
views on it for sure um and bitcoin's
qualities give rise
to these perceptions of it having
censorship resistance
or giving you transactional freedom or a
measure of transactional privacy
so because anyone can
operate a node and join the consensus
process and because mining is a
competitive free market process
that means that it's likely that
you can't be censored by the miners so
that means you have transactional
freedom so you have these
computer science technical features of
the system that cause it to have these
political qualities which is
it's very hard or impossible to censor a
specific individual
so it's it's interesting to see that
flow
but so that's one of the core values for
sure is the censorship resistance
then you have the fact that it's a
cryptographic based system
and uh you can hold value in your brain
by memorizing 12 words for instance
that gives it seizure resistance which
is again a political concept if you
wanted to
desert your jurisdiction with your
wealth intact in your brain
you know that you know cryptographic
feature of the system the fact that it's
built on public key cryptography
and that you can encode a bitcoin
private key
in 12 words that gives it this political
salience
that you know you can you're now
empowered relative to
a despot basically yeah i mean there's
so many beautiful concepts
behind cryptocurrency behind bitcoin
that stand for sort of freedom some of
the basic things at the founding of this
country
the one thing i don't like personally
behind
uh bitcoin and cryptocurrency is that
money is involved
and it's like people's lives savings
sometimes are involved
so there is naturally a kind of
fear a self-preservation
uh like instinctual kind of dogmatic
thing that comes in
where you're not the best of human age
so you're you stop being a george
washington
and you lose touch of the like
foundational principles which i think
are beautiful just like the founding
principles of this country
so that's that's just like um so i like
staying on the level of like the
philosophy
versus the level of like all my money is
invested in bitcoin
and that that becomes very tricky
territory to have
principal discussions yeah about ideas
well it's an interesting tension i try
to stay balanced despite being very
exposed to bitcoin
so
you